former Republican Senator Jeff Flake
says that at least 35 Republican
senators would vote to remove Donald
Trump if the Senate impeachment vote
were private so let's back up a little
bit the entire time I've been talking to
you about impeachment
I've been accurately saying I believe
that as long as Republicans control the
Senate Trump will not be removed by
impeachment the House Democrats can do
their impeachment inquiry if it leads
them to saying we are filing articles of
impeachment they can do it they can do
the impeachment trial but no matter what
once it goes to the
republican-controlled Senate which there
will be at least until January of 2021
and I believe until January of 2023
based on the the Senate election map you
are not going to remove Trump because
Republicans would not vote to convict
Trump on an impeachment charge now I've
not mentioned it but implied in this is
that impeachment votes in the Senate are
public the way you see senators vote on
stuff yay nay up a vote down vote the
way they do that they would publicly
vote on impeachment in that same way but
in the back of my mind and that of many
others was the question of imagine that
the Senate impeachment vote was not
public but instead it was private so at
the end of the vote you would get the
number of senators who voted to impeach
and the number of senators who voted to
acquit would you have some Republicans
who would be willing to vote for the
removal of Donald Trump if that's where
the evidence brought them would
Republican senators vote to impeach
Trump if they knew that their vote would
not be public and therefore they would
potentially not be subject to the
political repercussions of it and the
growing idea according to a couple of
reports is that the answer is yes we
first heard from Republican political
consultant might Mike Murphy and Mike
Murphy said on MSNBC that if the vote
was private 30 Republican senators would
back impeachment then we heard from
former Republican Senator Jeff Flake who
said it the Texas Tribune Festival over
the weekend that it's not or Thursday it
was it's not 30 Republican senators that
would vote to impeach Trump it's more
like a
least 35 who would back impeachment if
the impeachment vote were private and
because of the balance of power you
actually don't even need 30 or even 35
Republicans to get behind impeachment
you would only need about 20 assuming
that all Democrats and independent
senators voted for it but this is mostly
hypothetical because once again it's not
a private ballot it's a public valve
ballot just like everything that goes on
in the Senate there's one other element
to this which is it's not as simple to
say if the vote were private 35
Republicans would be in favor of it
because even if the vote were private
those Republican senators who vote
against impeachment would come out and
say afterwards even if it's a private
vote I voted against impeachment and
this would immediately put the spotlight
on the Republicans that don't come
forward and say I voted against
convicting and they would either have to
lie or admit it so it's sort of a
fantasy that it would even go down in
this way but what this signals then is a
huge cowardice on the part of the
Republicans because if it's true that
they're only willing to vote to impeach
if the vote is secret and it doesn't
have political ramifications for them
it's merely a political calculation now
the upside if we want to find a silver
lining here is that I guess they're not
all blindly loyal to Donald Trump
the downside is they're afraid to act on
it unless it's done in a way that it
will have no consequences whatsoever I
read a comment online when researching
the story that sums it up as they're not
all traitors some merely have no
integrity and it's not even just lack of
integrity there's also the issue of
hypocrisy because in addition to the
laki lacking integrity they would
instantly be voting to impeach a
Democratic president who had done all of
the things that Donald Trump has done
this may not even be a decision they end
up having to make were just at the
beginning of the inquiry which happens
before articles are filed which would
happen before all of the other things
that we've discussed but if Jeff Flake
is only 20% correct if Mike Murphy is
only 30% correct that means that there
would be the desire from enough
Republican
in the Senate to impeach that it could
remove Donald Trump but mark my words
you are not going to see it under this
current republican-controlled Senate
let's take a break we will be back with
much more right after this